so you never went to Reed Park in Mesa
uh a couple of times when I was younger
but I never really spent time [ __ ]
Park man yeah that Park's like that
Parks I used to walk there every night
and play basketball with a bunch of
[ __ ] Pisces I was like the only guy
who spoke English I was like [ __ ] 12
hooping with a bunch of like shout out
to all the Mexicans in Mesa but all the
guys were like shorter than me so it was
kind of tight you know what I mean
you know they're dunking up people he
was oh man but then but yo what's crazy
is I moved to Mesa right before Reed
park opened so me and my boys I thought
I was like oh let me try skating I'm
like I feel like I I I could at one
point in time I could pull off a
kickflip I could I could still probably
Ollie but my skating career was short
because we went to break in to read
before it opened but it was still like
you could see that oh it's a skate park
I just gotta hop over the fence but it
wasn't open to the public yet so we
jumped the wall
and then uh
I think the cops or somebody started to
pull up or whatever's cops up everywhere
over there and uh we try to jump the
fence to to run and my jeans got stuck
in the [ __ ] Spike at the top of the
fence I fell eight [ __ ] broke my hand
never skated again uh I was like ah this
is not for me I'm gonna just play Tony
Hawk that was a tragic experience yeah
you got to give it a try I guess so no
no no no no no no no no no
I am just not gonna work for me you
better just pop an ollie for the ground
Papa Ollie I think I could I think I
could pull an alley off hey how about
this Cyrus you're gonna give me that
[ __ ] look over there let's put some
[ __ ] money on it
I could I think I could steal all these
yeah I saw you I tie it I saw you had
Tyro they tied it on the board yeah
there's some good rappers uh Hopsin Rich
the kid solid Rich the kid be like Trey
flip downstairs like yeah I think I
think Hobson could get him though yeah I
think those are the two best that that
would be I think a good game with skate
is actually really good he's not as good
as as Hopson though well you know what's
crazy is like out so like Ty and Wayne
were on the same session and it was
funny because like I don't think like Ty
knew how good like Wayne is because
Wayne like Wayne be going to Tampa skate
park but he like skates like when you go
to the park like he's sliding the rail
like he's jumping down the stair like
and it was just crazy because Tyler was
like dang he was like man like I gotta I
gotta roll down that one right there and
I'm like yeah we could get you there
like you know me but he'd be like really
like he loves skating like he tried to
pull up many times you know any chance
he can get the skate and it's cool
because like he could roll in Wayne or
Ty
no no I'm saying like who are you
talking about right now oh uh right now
I'm talking about Ty dollar sign oh yeah
yeah Ty Dolla Sign yeah he'd been like
getting in at the park and like you know
I mean skating a [ __ ] thought yeah
I've known that guy for [ __ ] 10 years
I never knew he picked up a skateboard
yeah you gotta you gotta see he posted a
video here at the park uh he was smoking
cigarettes on the pocket like a real
[ __ ] degenerate though
yeah he was like yo can I smoke and I
always assume it's weed I'm like yeah of
course then he pulls out a [ __ ] pack
of cigarettes from Dubai
smoked three of them in the interview
I'm for we're all [ __ ] dying in here
it just smells like my dad
for sure
yeah so who do for you like your
experience who you think's the best
skating rapper
I would say man off the top of my head
like the best gay rapper I know like
I'll probably say Rich because like I've
seen like footage of him like Trey
flipping a Seven Stairs you know he's a
beast like you know what I mean I think
people don't understand how good he is
like he acts like Andy it's a skate park
in downtown L.A the barracks yeah and he
like always the tents there there he's a
beast like so people do not understand
Rich the kid is one of them guys he's
better than Wayne that's for sure oh
yeah I have for sure
yeah he skate skate like they gotta set
up the alt I try to set this up like
four years ago I tried to set up the
Hopsin verse Rich the kids game escape
and they were talking like stupid money
like I think they were selling like 100
Grand on the line and I don't remember
which side uh was not down but somebody
ended up backing out and but that would
have been epic yeah that would have been
crazy I saw uh Hopson had a show I
forgot uh what Chief any was but he has
somebody to come on stage and he played
them skate it was like some random dude
in the crowd yeah he does that he would
do that um every tour day he would just
say who wants to play skate before the
show behind the venue just playing
skating [ __ ] that's fire that's fire
yeah there's been uh what was the what
was it uh who's the rapper who uh tried
to rap it was signed the current or
signed a jet life uh what was the name
of the skater that turned into a rapper
was it Stevie uh the guy who was on uh
fly Society uh TK TK Kennedy yeah he's
in jail right
yeah I think right now he is yeah yeah
yo shout out to him too yeah shout out
to you very like he was a Pioneer in
fact it was like it was him like
obviously like when I got into skating
it was him Antoine Dixon
um Theodis Beasley like Windsor James
and like those dudes were like like yeah
the black skaters who was like really
like okay like you know we can do this
like you know yeah why Society was dope
he had a crazy chance yeah all the ice
cream ads like he was going crazy I
think he was dating Angela Simmons at
one point too oh [ __ ] good for you yeah
I think so yeah he was like in the whole
scene like he was like he had a TV show
too I remember he was going crazy I
don't I forget what he did but free him
maybe yeah I don't know I don't know
what he did so yeah maybe not for him I
don't know different about freeing him